[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to guano adventure
part 1
I hope you've survived those weird
camera shots that was just a bit of
experimentation with the new robotic
torque ride that we got in the newest
update which is really awesome for
cinematic shots of video but um that's
that's a topic for a whole nother day
this is a new series which is a little
bit experimental and I'll explain a bit
more why that is along the way but as a
very basic introduction
I haven't played planet coaster in quite
a long time just because I've been too
busy in Japan but now that I'm back I
finally have some time to catch up and
this is just one of those random little
things that I decided to build just to
kind of get used to the new pieces
especially the adventure updates and it
just kind of went so well then I figured
might as well turn this into a video of
a supposed new series and see how well
that video does so if this gets some
good reception
maybe this will actually get a follow-up
as well but for now it's just one Pike
entrance and I want to see where this is
kind of gonna go and the theming of this
is obviously since I was really doing it
as a bit of a test of the adventure pack
very much focused on adventure but I
will have to say it's with a little bit
of a twist I've never been much of a fan
for exactly following what the scenery
packs in the game want us to do and so
it's more of an more of a test to see
how far we can push the objects in the
adventure pack and to try to get used to
them as many of them as quickly as
possible and try to like use them in a
bunch of creative ways there's also a
few ODEs that I wanna give in this video
to some old roller coaster tycoon 3
creators who have been partly the
inspiration for this project first and
foremost lone wolf who does some amazing
stuff over at chango's WorldCom which is
still a great forum if you're interested
in any kind of amazing planet coaster
projects and he does a lot of adventure
type stuff so when I found the update it
was honestly one of the first creators
that I wanted to dig into a little bit
more to get some inspiration for the
adventure updates he was already doing
at
Oh themes way before this update came
out and back in the roller-coaster can
three days but even today in planet
coaster it's some really great stuff
with a very unique and recognizable
style so while I definitely don't want
to rip off that style
it was a huge inspiration especially in
the way that he blends different
materials together I don't think this
often gets a lot of recognition but it's
very difficult to use different types of
materials in a building to a good extent
it's for instance the way that he
combines wooden elements with stone
elements and so kind of combining very
soft and hard elements and textures of a
building together in a really great and
balanced way is something that I am
definitely a huge fan of a lot of his
buildings feature these stone walls and
basic structures but a lot of wooden
detailing and wooden elements that
overhang over paths or bring in some
kind of level of detail into any any
sort of building so that's really one of
my large inspirations here and hence the
main gates which is going to be the main
gates that people used to enter the park
is also this large wooden structure and
in a very adventurous tie adventure type
sense I suppose it's also been made
without nails or any kind of modern
techniques so to speak it's really just
some wooden logs and some rope holding
it all together in some kind of clumsy
way so it's a bit ancient in that sense
and I think it brings a good balance to
the rest of the building which is mostly
gonna be stone except for some of the
detailing and some of the path elements
which is again out of some wooden
features so we've got the main gate
which is that wooden part and then there
will be these large stone wings which
are not used to get into the park itself
ideally this Park is not going to be
that big because I do want to watch out
and not create too many series because
I've already got so much stuff running
at the moment but yeah for that reason
it's just got that main gaits to get
into the park and then the sites here
will be used for more you know kind of
important
things that you might need otherwise
like park information or toilets or I
forgot what I put in that other thing
but it was something like first aid I
believe so it's really that sort of
stuff that you need around up like
entrance which I'm putting in the wings
of the building but only the gates will
actually be used as the park entrance
itself I did realize that in this
episode at least I forgot to put some
turnstiles into the gates so people
might actually be able to walk straight
into the park that's something which I
would definitely have to fix at some
later points but for now just assume
that that Gates has some turnstiles in
it or something like that
in any case moving to the side of the
building and here I think it becomes
quite apparent that this is not just an
adventure building and that I'm not just
using the adventure pieces in a way that
they're supposed to be used because it's
a little bit the fantasy like and I kind
of want to give a shout out to Leonidas
here who's been a huge inspiration for
me ever since I started making videos
he's got a lot of really amazing stuff
in rollercoaster country he hasn't been
active in years in the community I
believe but it's still really great
stuff that even today is really cool to
look back at and his work always
featured a lot of and yeah there you go
spires so that's probably where that
thing comes from and you had a bunch of
projects where he would take different
types of fantasy like elements and
combine them all with a spire castle
like set up and in this case I wanted to
try something very similar even if this
is just an adventure type theme and if
this is more commonly used for temples
and that sort of stuff I wanted to try
something with spires and kind of mixing
it into a fantasy like feel so here we
go there's a small there's a few small
spires right next to the gates but
is really the first big tower and
there's gonna be a bunch more just to
create that whole fantasy facade and
silhouettes look for the entrance which
should also be really recognizable for
the park itself obviously a park
entrance should not just look great
because it's cool to have a nice-looking
building but it's also the first touch
or like the first idea that you get of
the park itself so I think it should
always be quite representative of what
kind of theme and what kind of scenery
you'll get inside the park so the fact
that six flex parks have just metallic
is simple little buildings out there the
front of their park is perfectly fine
because that perfectly represents what
six flag stands for but that awesome
efteling entrance with the real
fantastical wooden roofs and crazy beams
and detailing everywhere is something
that really represents the sort of
fantasy theme and architecture of the
efteling so in that sense I think it's
really important for a any kind of
entrance to be like the rest of the park
like that and look as nicely as possible
while doing it and at the same time it's
a bit of a weenie in itself you know
it's something which has to draw the
guests into the park and which has to
catch your attention right away it's of
course the first impression that you get
of the park and first impressions are
just always really important and really
important no matter what kind of thing
you're talking about now getting into
the second spire there's already a bit
of a trend here I suppose
in total this building will have 14
spires and I'm trying to make each of
them slightly unique from the other ones
there's only two copies which other ones
right to the left of the gates which are
symmetrical maybe I should have actually
done something with that but aside from
those they're all gonna be unique towers
so the whole building has entirely
slightly different looks all over the
thing and it's definitely not going to
be symmetrical at all
because I think as a building especially
as something that is trying to be
somewhat adventurous and fantasy like
it's much more interesting to have
something that's asymmetrical rather
than just copying things left and right
one of the things which also inspired me
a little bit for this build are some of
the Chinese parks which are being built
in China right now which is a little bit
of an untapped market as far as theme
park reporting but also inspiration and
planet coaster go since China is going
through a middle-class boom right now
and as a result it's also going through
a theme park boom and what's really
interesting is that they're building a
lot like I cannot keep up with the
amount of theme parks that they're
building right now they're building a
lot of theme parks and yet they're all
putting a lot of money into them as well
and they end up being a little bit like
Disney ripoffs and very reminiscent of
parks in the rest of the world but they
also do some really daring and
interesting things and surprisingly a
lot of them managed to combine really
heavy theming with extreme
rollercoasters as well and some of the
biggest and most known chains of these
parks are the Phantom wild parks and the
happy valley parks and both of these
sort of a little bit as the inspiration
here but also in some of my other parks
to be very honest because even though
they do steal a lot of ideas and
sometimes they just end up being kind of
weird into experimental they do also do
some really cool stuff that's not
noticed by a lot of people and a lot of
that theme parks have a very fantastical
kind of adventurous or fantasy or
european-style architecture to them
which is interesting scene seeing that
it's from the lens of a completely
different culture and I'm trying a
little bit of a similar thing in here
when I'm just shoehorning these spires
into the adventure theme I guess in a
similar way that Fanta Wilde parks like
to shoehorn everything on to Disney
Console clones so there's a bit of
inspiration from that as well the final
shoutouts I have to give to n7 also
known as I
sir or also known as one half of Planet
bro coaster who have probably given
enough shoutouts in the past already but
their work is totally awesome so I'll be
leaving a link to that and definitely
check out their park it's way more
grounded in reality than this is but
those guys have been at this game and at
wala co second three for so many years
already and they're a huge inspiration
to me as well but especially n7 since he
had this one ride called noob guano in
roller-coaster country which was
absolutely ridiculous but it had this
kind of adventurous jungle Mayan temple
kind of theme and that's also where the
name guano in this part comes from so
it's Evan if you're listening to this
thanks for all the years of great
inspiration and keep up the good work in
planet coaster as well anyway I I just
keep talking about different things for
a few minutes and then there's already
bunch more spires in this park we're
starting on the the left side of the
building and even though I said that I
wanted this building not to be very
symmetrical I at least want to bring a
little bit of balance in terms of how
heavy each side of the building feels
think it's important even if you're not
building in a very symmetrical way to at
least have a proper sense of balance of
elements and mass of the building so on
the right side we've got some towers
which are quite large and quite thick
and they're really close to the center
of the building and on the left side
here we've got something
slightly smaller and lower towers but
they are a little bit further out to the
left so I think that well balances out
the weight of both the towers on both
sides not to mention that there's
obviously going to be some detail in the
building itself as well and that there's
gonna be a bunch more spires than just
these few things but yeah that's just a
basic idea that's really really hard to
explain I always have a tough time
explaining how to get a proper feel for
how a building is composed because
honestly I don't have any idea either
and I also don't have any background in
architecture or anything like that that
it's just
certain thing that I guess you develop
over time if you do this kind of thing
for long enough where you can feel when
a building feels rights in terms of
composition and scale and when a
building feels wrong there's not much
that you can explain in terms of saying
that the composition is off or that it's
not balanced well but there's just
something about it that feels off and
it's always really hard to put these
things into words but at least with a
very simple structure at least
composition wise like this one where
you've got that main Gable in the front
and then just flat sections to the sides
with spires on top of them it's a little
bit easier to bring the building into a
sense of balance that feels like it's
just right so yeah that's what I'm going
for here and then we've got some slight
detailing on the sides here just to make
things interesting because after all
this is just a rectangular building with
some straight walls I wanted to add a
lot of variation in terms of textures so
we've got some pieces with those jungle
stone walls and then some other pieces
with those regular old stucco walls I
believe no render I think it is and some
slightly different uses of color and
some detailing as well like some of
these stuff that you can stick to the
walls to give it some extra patterns
here and there it's just some of the
ways I think in which you can make a
building more interesting even if that
building is very boring
in terms of shape usually I would
totally recommend against making
rectangular buildings when you're
revealing a very important building like
a coaster station or an important weenie
or something like that always try to
incorporate all kinds of different
shapes and not just go for a rectangular
building shape because it's really hard
to make a rectangular building look good
but for a Pike entrance I think it's
somewhat justified you've always got a
very similar kind of setup with many
park entrances usually there is some
sort of gates in the middle as you can
see with for instance Europa park's
large glass ironwork entrance or the
Hollywood Studios large arches or
even the wannabe Holland arch at the
front of the park which is ugly as it
may be it still has that same structure
you still have that sort of main gaits
in the middle and then some buildings
printing out to the sides and being
gradually lower than the middle section
is so really when it comes to park
entrances I think in most cases you can
see this kind of composition as a
template and you can really attach any
kind of theme to this general build
whatever doesn't really matter so much
but it's it's this kind of shape which
you see with most entrances it even goes
if they're really small if you take
trips trails entrance for instance this
is just a tiny German park with some
traditional German architecture it still
has that very similar main gates which
in their case is really small and then
some stuff to the side which is lower
and throwing the guests less toward it
now with that said I believe if I
remember correctly that is just about it
for the building of the entrance itself
but obviously to give the entrance some
form of belonging in a world of the the
imaginary theme park which we have here
I did want to do some of the theming
around it especially foliage because
putting foliage in front of the building
just makes the building seem so much
more at home and gives you a much better
idea what the building would look like
in context so in this case since this is
an adventure park I finally got to use
those new palm trees which I have to say
they're absolutely awesome definitely
prefer these over the palm trees that
were in game earlier as well I think
they're really good and quite realistic
and one of the things which are still
really impressive to me about the trees
and which is one of the reasons why most
likely fronds here hasn't made more
trees use their movement in the wind
it's really well done and it looks
really realistic even if on these time
lapses it looks a bit strange because
it's you know sped up twelve times it's
one of those small touches which
definitely adds a breath of life into
the game oh and finally I didn't want to
clean up the backside of the building
kind of forgot about that for a bit
there is not really anything
on the back because I honestly couldn't
be really bothered to work on that so
this video would also become way too
long if I was also going to finish
something on the back side but at least
I wanted to make it look clean for now
also the sign in front of the entrance
says guano Gardens but that's a name
which I had for a while but I think
after thinking about it for a bit I
think one Oh adventure is less generic
and more speaks about what this is
actually about theme wise so I think
that's a slightly better name and then
for the rest of this I'm just kind of
trying to tidy up the parks a little bit
I removed some of the curbs on these
paths because I'm not a huge fan of the
curbs on those stone paths but I am a
fan of the paths themselves so I had to
insert my own little curbs there and
then there are some simple path elements
like lights and that little fire in the
middle because I wanted some sort of
central element there but I didn't want
something which would obscure the
entrance building itself so I thought
that was a pretty good thing to do there
and finally of course we have to go into
foliage and get a bit of an idea of what
kind of foliage the rest of this is
gonna have and I honestly haven't played
around much with the new foliage in the
game either but I think it looks it
looks absolutely stunning definitely
hope that we get more more of this level
kind of foliage in the game over time
because it's absolutely amazing and with
each little plants or shrubbery that we
get there's just so many more options in
terms of theme especially because the
adventure pack is really versatile even
outside of this tropical adventure theme
but I'll be trying to stick with that
here hence there's a bunch of palm trees
and tropical trees in the area in any
case that's just about it for the time
lapse but I do have some final shots
which I still want to kind of compensate
over a little bit so this is the view as
you come into the entrance and you get
those really cool towers in the distance
with that really really fantasy
adventure like style and this is it at
night I decided to put in the efforts to
actually add some lights into the
building as well
and it might seem strange that I'm
already getting to this stage but
there's a quite important reason why I
decided to do that because as you might
be able to realize when you look at the
building right here from this aerial
perspective there we go comes in view a
little bit more and there you have it
it's April Fool's and the joke is on you
because I am NOT going to do anything
with this series I have just been trying
to spell out the word April Fool's for
20 minutes without realizing and if I
succeeded in that then oh boy I am sorry
but you probably just wasted all that
time because I am NOT continuing this
series I was just messing around with
the adventure theme to be very honest
and there is just no way in hell that I
should even start a new series to begin
with because there are too many things
that I need to finish right now but if
you enjoyed this video even if this is
not gonna be continued and even if it
was never serious
then I guess you're welcome and if you
didn't then you're welcome to because I
enjoyed bamboozling you in any case
thanks for watching guys and I'll see
you in the next hopefully serious video
bye bye